what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
have been thinking for like the last day
or so which we're doing so much infinity
war stuff like Avengers for stuff which
it is kind of fun it is pretty cool um
we're probably like tapered this off
next week and just go back to like one
video what we talking about Avengers
four I have no idea depends on how much
you guys like this stuff
and how many topics we can think up but
but like I'm and thinking about this for
the last couple days or so and I have no
evidence to support this claim
whatsoever but I think it would be so
amazing if like if like Avengers forgave
us heart of the monster slash world
breaker Hulk because both of both
versions are like stupid powerful like
they're insanely powerful okay so here's
the deal alright for though you guys I
don't know about these two versions of
the Hulk they are they're nuts like
they're there they are
it's crazy okay so all this goes back to
like the Illuminati and Planet Hulk
right like the Illuminati miniseries are
really the Illuminati one shot establish
the idea that light travels well not
Charlie Xavier he wasn't there um bit
like Doctor Strange and iron man and
like they were the Submariner and the
various members of the Illuminati had
come to the conclusion that the
Incredible Hulk was too powerful and too
unpredictable and so they were gonna
kick him off of Earth right they're
gonna be like okay you gotta go so they
trick him onto a spaceship with the help
of like Nick Fury like the classic white
Nick Fury who's like he's like the
unseen now which is kind of kind of cool
but they haven't done anything with it
but they trick him on to a spaceship and
then like it's like the most dick move
ever Reed Richards plays a recording and
it's like sorry Hulk you're too
unpredictable so you can't be on earth
anymore and so their intention was to
send him to like a peaceful planet right
well the problem is he ends up flying
feel like a gravity well or something
like that and and the result is that he
ends up on this war-torn planet called
sac our to make a long story short uh he
basically conquers the existing king of
Sekar and then in turn after forming his
warbound kind of like this gladiatorial
team he rises to be like the sac arson
like the new king of the car and then
like starts a family with this chick
named named Kai air who's pregnant with
his kid
well somebody messed with the ship the
the nuclear engine basically goes off
and like detonates this massive nuclear
bomb which kills everybody including his
wife and what he believes to be his
unborn son his son actually lived but uh
but he thought his son was dead man like
dude the incredible an incredible all
goes on a warpath because like he blames
the Illuminati right he's like it was
your ship it was your design
it blew up like you guys cost me
everything I loved after kicking me off
the earth
so the Incredible Hulk like basically
like he grabs his warbound and he's like
okay so we're gonna go back to earth and
and we're just gonna bring help so like
they they travel they travel back to
earth right they stop at the moon it's
like the first place they stop at where
the Inhumans live in blackboard of the
Inhumans is there and and like like he
just crushes him I mean you just easily
the craziest things like I want to hear
you scream and like like crushes like
crushes his arms or crushes his hands
rather and just like like decimates
blackballed which is not the most
impressive thing ever
the next stop is the most impressive
thing he shows up at the no that's not
even the most impressive thing he shows
up at the Xavier Institute all right
Xavier is backed by this point because
House of them basically ended and Xavier
is returned and any did he show us with
these Adrian City it's like okay x-men
like I want to see Xavier and I don't
want to see him now I want to see him
right now and so like like he's like
he's like I want this like bring him out
here or I will come in there and get him
and so like the x1 or like oh hey we're
the you know so they come running out
you know like we got a person Xavier you
know someone stuff with Colossus shows
up right Colossus has like his osmium
form is organic metal skin and like he
goes to attack those goes to like fight
the incrediblelife like world breaker
Hulk and we record Hulk just like breaks
his arms like just break some like twigs
you know it's the craziest thing to ever
happen and so it's like damn dude like
this is this is bonkers and so it looks
like he just rolls through the x-men
well then come like the next couple
contingents it's like Wolverine and like
Cyclops and world worker hoax like -
dude really guys like come on man
and just like crushes every likes one of
them right just like just like
steamrolls them I mean it's it's the
craziest thing
it's like he's steamrolls like all the
x-men they call juggernaut that was
always when I was reading it at the time
they call him Jevon and I'm like oh yeah
some do they call him juggernaut dude
the dude is unstoppable right so they
bring in juggernaut juggernaut ghostie
attack The Incredible Hulk he's running
at him and like he just grabs him and
like diverts his movement and just sends
him flying then he's like next like any
anybody else you know I so like Xavier
finally comes out and and I basically
tells him everything that happened and
then Xavier is like I probably would
have done the same thing the rest of the
Illuminati did I wouldn't have banned
you permanently but like I would have
done the same thing for the most part
and the incredible hulks like whatever
and then like once he realizes like 98%
of the mutant population lost their
powers then like Xavier powers are gone
all that kind of stuff but he's like
whatever you suffered enough and leaves
so he goes back to Manhattan right now
The Incredible Hulk gets to Manhattan
what follows is one of the most
spectacular astral beings of the history
of comics The Incredible Hulk Rex the
gamma core which is basically a group of
individuals who were gamma-powered
using the incredible Hawks energy he
rushed The Mighty Avengers the New
Avengers Captain America Captain America
Doctor Strange possessed by a demon Iron
Man and the Hulkbuster armor the
Fantastic Four I mean just like crushes
everyone this is a coolest thing ever
just like
rules like just steamroll small that's
ultimately like the whole story boils
down to the century Robert Reynolds
who's basically Marvel's MacGuffin you
know and so he comes he comes flying in
and they fight to a standstill the
Sentry who seizes all his power he
eventually goes back to his human form
Bruce Banner reverts back to his human
form and then Tony Stark fires these you
know weaponized satellites and whatever
Bruce banners taken captured into story
now that goes into like a whole host of
stories after that that deal with things
like like a bomb who's a really weird
and crazy idea for like basically Rick
Jones who becomes incredible who becomes
like a Hulk
whatever none of that stuff matters
there's things like Red Hook which is
actually is pretty cool red hole
basically defeated Silver Surfer and
soulless like stole a surfboard but like
that goes into a story called heart of
the monster Hulk now world breaker hawk
was strong I mean there was a point in
the story where like he stomped on the
ground and shook the entire East Coast
and so it's just like damn this is crazy
part of the monster Hope deals with a
wishing well and I think Bruce Banner
basically makes the where I'm sorry the
incredible what makes the wish or
whatever to basically be allowed to like
fight his enemies forever and so he's
transported to the Dark Dimension the
dimension of Dormammu alright like Umar
I think don't wanna sisters the one
who's ruling it but like these are not
weak people right they're not like you
know like like Emma Frost or the x-men
with like telepathy and who you know is
talking about like super powerful beings
then if they chose to invade the Marvel
Universe they would give everyone a run
for their money and so like like the
incredible Hawks transported there and
like he's facing pretty much like all
his enemies and like he just keeps
getting angrier and angrier and angrier
and more and more powerful and becomes
like part of the monster Hulk now the
only way that we really know how
powerful heart of the monster Hulk is is
one their fight is destroying an entire
dimension and so like boom R comes to
the main Marvel Universe and it's like
hey Steven strange you got to get this
dude the hell out of here because like
they're destroying my reality because
they're so powerful like it's it's crazy
how strong it was and then there's a
story where like I think in that same
story
Fin Fang Foom who's like this weird
dragon thing ends up is or me like all
this gamma radiation it kind of goes
like kind of runs amuck and then like
Amadeus Cho who's like this super smart
sidekick kind of a Bruce Banner of The
Incredible Hulk
it's like hey dr. strange we should get
like you know the Hulk in like the Dark
Dimension or whatever it is and dr.
strange like absolutely not because that
guy Dwarfs world breaker hawk it's crazy
they said in the stories
he Dwarfs world breaker hole this heart
of the monster Hulk if he shows up here
he'll destroy the world like he'll
destroy it in a punch like that's that's
how powerful he was he was so powerful
he could crush gods like entire gods it
was it was insane how powerful he was
just just like this all he looks so
badass there's like this full panel
spread of heart of the monster hawk
where he's just like ah you know it's
just like massive in size it's crazy how
he ji got but like like we probably
won't see those in Avengers 4 but let me
tell you if we did man I mean like hard
a monster hope wouldn't be able to stop
like the Infinity Gauntlet but like like
heart of the monster Hulk vs Thor not a
chance I'm sorry versus like Thanos not
a chance Thanos would just get crushed
by heart of the monster hole it would
even be a contest like it wouldn't it
wouldn't even be fair but the question
is like like how do we get to that point
right like if we got world breaker Hulk
for example just like super strong
Incredible Hulk who could still probably
crush Thanos like like if we had that
version of the Hulk how do we get it
because like the events that gave us
world breaker Hulk are totally different
from like the events that have
transpired and infinity war so far okay
a little bit of a spoiler or people
haven't seen the movie yet not a great
big huge spoiler but a little bit of a
thing at the egg with infinity war when
like half the unit half the universe
dies and like all those different you
know characters on earth die there are
two two main characters that we don't
know the fate of the first is Pepper
Potts in the second is Betty Ross we
don't know what happened to them we
haven't seen neither hide nor hair of
Betty Ross since like the original
Edward Norton Incredible Hulk movie for
all we know she's been sitting around
watching the view eating bonbons putting
on 50 pounds and you know crying because
her life didn't turn out the way she
wanted to who the hell knows like I mean
there's any number of things she could
be doing and so like like if if like the
whole event of Avengers 4 takes place
and like banner tries to reason with The
Incredible Hulk and The Incredible Hulk
won't listen and banners like dude we
have to do something everyone we know is
dead Betty Ross is dead then like in
like Thanos is the one they killed her
like that could set the hulk off and
just leta snaps just loses it and just
like goes berserk on fan o's
now at us with like the the Infinity
Gauntlet would still crush me I mean
you're talking about like a really
strong version of the Hulk versus a guy
who can control the fundamental forces
of the universe so it's not a contest
but still like like I mean it would be
cool because we don't really
oh how they gone the works right now I
still say it's fully powered but Marvel
could change that and so I thirst
there's any number of things that could
go on but like it would be insane like I
mean like like that fight between the
Hulk and Thanos in infinity war against
wall breaker Hulk
it would be half as long and it'd be
like one punch and like like whole
quarter there's been like BAM done
anybody else like that's that that's
exactly how that would have gone it
would it would've just been it would
have been the easiest fight ever it
would have been blockers but still like
I think that would be so cool to see
that version of The Incredible Hulk on
there because then like who knows how
that story could go right like we get
world breaker Hulk who let's say the
Infinity Gauntlet weaker than it's
supposed to be you're like Dan'l's can't
use it effectively or something like
that and like there's an opening there
for world breaker hope to manifest and
then like crush Thanos well then now
like rule breaker Hulk if he's you know
if he if he it depends on what they do
if they take like the mind a part of the
monster Hulk where all he wants to do is
fight and they combine it with like the
power of world breaker Hulk which would
actually make him weaker than the heart
of the monster version if they take
those two things and put them together
then like now he becomes an enemy of the
Avengers and like they have to find a
way to defeat him like you do that would
that would be crazy like it'd be the
most bonkers thing ever but I don't know
I mean that's the cool thing is like we
don't know like we can't even guess
about Avengers for like an infinity war
blue so many so many speculation
theories out of the water that there was
I mean aside from like a singular event
that everybody predicted because of what
the trailer told us that's there's like
nothing out there's almost nothing else
that anybody could possibly have gotten
right about that movie and if they did I
would say that it's probably sheer luck
like that movie just changed so many
expectations on what we saw coming that
like then it turns into okay like who
the hell knows what's gonna happen with
infinity war so it's it's it's cool I
mean this probably won't happen I don't
see any reason why it would I mean it
would be it'd be too many stories thrown
into what's basically been like a linear
story so far because infinity war and
Avengers 4 are basically that like a
singular movie split into two parts
which we knew it was going to be
something like that because originally
it was Avengers infinity war parts 1 & 2
so like it's it's it's crazy in terms of
like how this can unfold and like what
can come out of it
it could be bonkers but I'm I'm excited
because of what happens like I'm super
excited but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section
because I'm kind of curious what your
all's ideas are on like what will happen
in Avengers
or let me know what you guys think I'll
happen with with the Incredible Hulk
like that's what I'm kind of curious
about let me know what you guys think
will happen with the Incredible Hulk
because I'm curious to see what some of
the theories are that you come up with
because you guys think of stuff that
like I never would have thought of in a
million years where does one of the
reasons why the rob4 so awesome anyway
if you guys are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Robin Corps
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]